okay welcome back
Peter Bick what can an everyday person
do to reduce carbon in the world when
paying attention you don't have to
anymore we got a big [ __ ] magic
vacuum to suck it out vote vote vote for
the right people yeah that's I agree
vote for the right people that's really
the biggest thing right it isn't really
a job that is so big only government can
do it don't you think that only ever no
agree no what you think private industry
is going to save us from the if you're
that concerned about it put a big tax on
gasoline yes big tax on oil and what
will cause a change in behavior and a
reduction of emissions what about ozone
Marvin tax right you Matt would you want
a carbon tax do you want a tax on carbon
well that might be the way to do it I'm
rather potent you have to have an
opinion I would put it on the barrel of
oil that we use for every purpose
industrial transportation but again and
everything else not to be mr. broken
record but it's another case where there
is no left on this issue
why should there nor know yeah you go
all the way really to the president for
a carbon tax well this is I haven't
heard it no he's not even for a gas tax
right is his energy secretary had to eat
his words for about three years for for
proposing it before he was in the job
now that is why we have crony capitalism
that is why we're not meeting any of
these huge problems facing the country
okay Bob you offered a beautiful eulogy
for Stan mutual Oh from your hometown
right hey Lois what is one lesson
today's athletes could take away from
his career well I guess there are some
that follow this path but not enough
grace and humility you can still be
exciting you can still have style you
don't have to call attention to yourself
in some sort of like self aggrandizing
exhibitionistic way the guy just can got
it in himself with style you got a love
watching the basketball players
they mean like the University of
Louisville fighting Cardinals men's
basketball team by any chance would you
be an alum of would I be in Louisville
I'm not no not born and raised born and
raised but there they were humble yeah
they were good they weren't they were by
and large good and the way they reacted
after Kevin Ware's injury was very
classy yeah but I must say even I when I
play basketball now because I've been
watching the players on TV Oh Lissie
when I hit a good shot you grab your
crotch I grab Mike I do that thing you
know you know just as a small measure
how about this could players in the NBA
not have to high-five after every foul
shot even if they miss right if they
miss it you [ __ ] [ __ ] you missed a
foul shot and you have to get that
affirmation from everybody on your team
yeah
[Applause]
oh and that's why I drink ladies [ __ ]
you what it's a nightmare
okay Stephanie we'll Voting Rights be as
much an issue in future elections as
they were in 2012 or I would add to that
do you think since it didn't work right
it cheating do you think they'll try it
again that's that's what I was gonna say
that was there you know a big part of
their electoral strategy and that's how
they were gonna win by denying people
access to the vote it didn't work it may
have incited more people we used it that
way right don't let them take this away
from you we still had you know lines
that were seven hours long ten hours
long so we have no idea how many people
weren't able to vote but you know
whoever runs for president in the next
four years
whoever's running the Democratic Party
at that point has got to put a big
investment into making sure that we
didn't have Gerry Perry if we didn't
have cheating if people got the right
information we would find it to be a
much more liberal country than it is
then it's not really he's not really a
50/50 good wouldn't be neat if we had
one person one vote in the United States
if what one person one vote yeah he
calls through get rid of the electoral
college nice yeah yeah David Stockman
what do you say all right what do you
say to an economist like Paul Krugman
who argued that the only way to solve
our economic problems is through growth
and that now is a good time to spend
money on things like high-speed rail and
other major government initiatives I
mean it is true money has never been
cheaper am i right yeah money has never
been cheaper because it's been made that
way by the Federal Reserve right and the
money that they're making zero never
gets out of Wall Street it's used by
speculators it's used by gamblers to
make huge amounts of windfalls all going
to the 1% it's not going into Main
Street and so therefore I think the
policy of the Fed is totally wrong it's
not helping period but what if we I mean
if we bought Bart I mean what does it
cost today to borrow a hundred billion
dollars well not much right like that's
a billion or so you know that's the
point that's pretty cheap to get a loan
like that what could we do with a
hundred
in wise is more expensive to take money
out of an ATM you're right and then they
won't let you take more than 200 bucks
video charge me four dollars let me take
out a thousand right yeah but I did your
training oh no I'm just I'm just I'm
just glad I own the Mets Bob as a
broadcaster how would you address the
history of racism and sexism at the
Augusta National Golf Club why is it
Bob's job my god II already told Sun
canonically talen actually came up
earlier today on on Dan Patrick show um
over the years over you're doing another
show today Bob it was it was a radio
show you were cheating as a radio show
over over the years because the Masters
is such an important television property
and they hold such a tight rein on the
broad sounds racist right off the bat
yeah the masters right CB CBS CBS pretty
much has to dance to their tune Jack
Whittaker steamed great broadcaster
years and years ago called the gallery
at Augusta a mob and because of that he
was banned for several years Gary McCord
once said these greens are so slick it
looks like they put bikini wax on them
and that was unacceptable and he was
banned that hasn't been back in years
and years I don't even get what that
means
now that it would be slicked in but why
is that in something I don't know it's
not it's not up to standards but in in
it in any case in any case I would buy
office I would look I would just say
that I would have had to as a horrible
sport it's an insult it's not it is a
nice blur I would have had to of a Greta
for it I would have been a glutton I
would have insisted on a dress of
impressing their history
and I would have been thrown off the
broadcast that's the way it works
it's like making running around the
block a Sportage it's terrible all right
we got to go thank everybody Real Time
with Bill Maher Friday night at 10:00
ask Bill and his guests to agressions
right after the show at HBO calm